As we already said before, direct
mapped, and fully associated caches
can be considered to be just special
cases or set of associated caches.
So for example,
a direct mapped cache, is actually
a 1-way set associative cache.
And a fully associative =
N-way SA where N = # of lines.
For all this caches,
the address that the processor supplies
is broken into the offset,
index and tag components.
The number of offsets bits is
the number of bits that we need to
tell us where in the block size we are.
So it's log2 (block size).
The number of index bits
is log2(# of sets) we have.
In a direct mapped cache,
that is the number of blocks we have.
In a fully associative cache,
that's 1, so log2 of that is 0,
and we have no index bits.
And the tag bits are the remaining bits.
When you're trying to figure out
which bits are the index bits,
we actually need to know which
bits are the offset bits, too.
Because knowing that we have,
for example,
three index bits doesn't really tell us
whether they're here, or here, or here.
That depends on the offset bits.
So make sure that when you're
determining these bits,
you do it in that order.
First figure out how many
offset bits then the next so
many bits are indexed bits and
then the rest is the tag.